how much do you obsess over the first 10
minutes of your own movies
it's a really good question I think the
first 10 minutes or the most important
part
Steve Sable who created NFL films was my
mentor when I I worked in NFL films was
my first job out of school he said you
want a really strong open a really
strong close and keep everything in
between really short so I think you
wanna the first 10 minutes you really
have to grab people really the first one
minute now because people's attention
spans you know sometimes they're they're
watching on their phone or if they're
not interested they're just clicking I
know myself now was streaming like on
Netflix my wife will get mad at me
because I'm like oh let's turn this off
she's like it's three minutes in and I'm
like I don't like I'm not into it so uh
even my patience has worn thin and it's
something I
I knew I wanted to do with my scripted
feature and it's funny uh in the script
it worked fine but when I watched it it
opens up with driving maybe the most
boring thing you can open a movie with
is two people in a car driving now we
really filmed them driving it wasn't
like green screen or anything but
driving's boring like everybody does
driving to me it's not the most dynamic
way to start something so what we did is
we actually opened the film with like a
really dramatic moment and then put like
four days earlier because I just wanted
to show people like hey some cool shit's
gonna happen stay tuned you know so just
be give me 10 minutes something big is
gonna happen here and it's not just a
father and son driving on a road trip I
mean I was watching this I'm like oh my
God
gotta have something else here so yeah
and a close is really important you know
when I watched my movie for the first
time
in front of an audience you know I do
you cringe a little bit sometimes like I
wish I would do this differently I could
do that but I think like the best thing
my movie is going for me or like the
last 10 to 15 minutes like they you know
they move man and it's it's like it
really gets going and it's like end
strong because what you leave people
with is the most important thing I don't
know if you've ever seen the movie Field
of Dreams yeah Field of Dreams has that
like classic moment where Kevin Costner
goes hey Dad do you want to have a catch
and then then he and his father who is a
ghost or have a catch and everyone loves
that movie but if you actually sit and
watch the whole movie there's a lot of
weird stuff going on before that there's
a lot of
dips in that but people just remember
that feeling you left them with and uh
like wow
great movies one of my favorite movies
because of that ending so strong open
strong close 100 and then keep it short
in the middle I think so I mean that's
my I like shorter movies I know I'm not
I'm not the Prototype of like like
cinema at all of like who you would
think like like I don't you know I I
don't like long movies I mean I like the
Batman I really that was three hours and
I like top gun Maverick and I I do like
popcorn entertainment movies uh
I don't
I don't like that many independent
movies to be honest with you it can be
boring I mean you know I I do like to be
entertained
um and I do have ADHD so I'm willing to
say it's probably me I'm the issue it's
like that Taylor Swift song like I'm the
problem it's me so uh I don't deny that
so I wanted for me for this in my
independent film to have like some
Thrills like some action uh some stuff
to keep you invested in it not just to
have like two people talking in a an
apartment
but I think what's great is when someone
who doesn't necessarily like independent
cinema or when someone doesn't
necessarily like sports but when they
see something in that genre and they
can't stop watching it then I think you
have a real Masterpiece because if
you're getting people from outside of
that sphere that's not your audience and
they love it you know the last dance I I
watched every episode but it's not
something I would have sought out yeah
but once I watched one I was ready to
watch the rest of them and and I've been
at restaurants where 30 for 30 is
playing and I can't my I can't stop
focusing on it yeah that's what I've
tried to do
um I did a one of the 30 for 30s they
did was called I hate Christian Laettner
and has a kind of a catchy title and all
ESPN said is they wanted to do something
on this player Christian Laettner and I
was like who like like I didn't even
kind of remember who he was he just
instead though it became kind of like
hate in sports like the fun version of
hating and like what's it mean to be a
hater and why why do we like hating
something more than liking it like we
can we we're more into booing something
than cheering so then it kind of became
fun and pop culture and that goes back
to trying to find something that you
like in the subject so people might not
necessarily have even known who that
player was or not much about them but
they could get into the story because of
just the whole idea of it and
that kind of thing
and what did you walk away from once
that project was done what did you what
was kind of your take about media from
doing a film well perception perception
is not reality I think it was a big one
for instance Christian Laettner went to
Duke University they have a reputation
of being kind of
hoity-toity elitist and back then he
Christian late in a war like like
sweaters and had that kind of kind of
had a like a real like frat boy haircut
and look but it turned out he grew up in
Buffalo New York
and people found out he went to a prep
school but he was on a scholarship for
the prep school and he was on a work
program where he worked as a part of the
custodial staff and his mom was a school
teacher and his dad worked in a factory
so I don't think perception is reality
and I think especially now
I see it and I actually feel really
blessed with my work that I get to meet
so many different kinds of people from
different socioeconomic backgrounds
different race and I find so much more
unites us and separates us and I've met
people like if I just knew them on
Twitter I'd be like oh I I can't but
then when you're having a face to face
or you share a meal with them you
realize that
in person you know we we have a lot more
in common and so
I think it's important to get to know
people and you know that's one thing
that's a shame like with covid we lost a
lot of that with people became a little
more isolated and insulated more in like
a circle and bubble so
you know I think it's important to get
out there and realize that perceptions
aren't reality it's it's good to get to
know people sometimes perceptions are
reality too you can learn that
um so I feel fortunate in my work that
I've gotten to travel the world and meet
all different kinds of people
um and and I've found that for the most
part we're the same
and is that part of what you do in your
work when you take on a story about
someone that you're there to sort of
shatter that perception
hopefully I mean I I try to again make
the subject relatable for instance I did
a 30 for 30 on a wrestler Ric Flair and
you you see this guy and you're like
first of all some people don't like
wrestling just right off the Jump
they're like wrestling no thank you and
it's like well
what does it take to become a wrestler
what what kind of what do you have to go
through what's the work ethic that you
need what's the passion that goes into
it so we kind of broke that down like
the training he went through how he
learned how to throw a fake punch and he
would he talked about like hitting a
barely hitting a string in his doorway
and all the things so that you're
learning about this guy and suddenly it
becomes more about a passion doesn't
matter what it is the same way someone
can be into cooking or you you watch
Euro Dreams of Sushi and you don't have
to like sushi but you're just so much
respect
Excellence so it's like suddenly it
became what makes the greatest wrestler
in the world the greatest because
wrestling's predetermined it's not like
you can look at Tom Brady and say well
he has all these stats and that makes
him the greatest quarterback because he
has the best stats wrestling's not it's
predetermined it's choreographed so how
do you determine who the greatest
wrestler is so going into that
um I think people a compliment was you
know I don't really like wrestling but I
enjoyed that film so that that was huge
to me
how much of a story is Artistic vision
and how much is it audience
sort of like catering to the audience
that will be there for that figure
you know there's going to be detractors
or or supporters of a certain let's say
sports figure
it's a balance you you got to strike
that balance between
people that already know maybe a lot
about it so you don't want to dumb
things down for them like where I've
already seen this or they're they're
kind of treating me like I'm stupid
versus people that know nothing about
the subject you've got to ride that so
for the Nature Boy documentary it fell
into that every everything up until that
point not not any longer but up until
that point I had seen on wrestling
either fell into two categories it was
like really simplistic like like did you
know like they wrestling is
predetermined they're or like they break
it down like you've never even seen this
before and they also kind of like talk
down to you like like that it's like a
kind of not a it's a dumb Endeavor or
they're looking at the underbelly of the
profession that it's the Shady
skeevy thing and the bad stuff happens
during it like steroids and and misogyny
and things like that so I wanted to do
something that appealed to wrestling
fans like myself who love love it and
and get the spectacle and the enjoyment
and can live vicariously through the
performers and all that but also be able
to explain it to somebody like my wife
and make it more about the character
like yes this is outlandish but and in
this case this it was about how the
subject had actually become the
character he was playing like he the
lines became completely blurred between
the real guy and this wrestler so uh I
try to do both you definitely want to
consider who your audience is uh for
sure and where
where what you're what you what you're
doing where is it going to play
so it was almost like a method actor
that took it too far
kind of a thing somewhat I mean
wrestling wrestling's unique because
it's not like you hear like cut and and
back then in the 1980s they were still
trying to completely keep up the
illusion that it was all on the up and
up that they really hated these guys
each other they wouldn't travel with
each other like they they had to be
separate hotels and and all of that so
you they call it like living the gimmick
that you would do it so
the character of Ric Flair was this like
you know
big Playboy uh a different a different
woman every night in a different Hotel
private planes kind of like almost ahead
of its time as far as like the bravado
telling everybody how great he was and
he became that guy what what was he
always that guy I don't know you know I
didn't there's not that much documented
in him but the lines definitely blurred
between the real guy and the the Nature
Boy so and he paid he paid a price for
it too he lost the Sun and had some
tragedy in his life